foreign
er's in Tampa Florida hi Tyler welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
it's an honor to speak with you you too
what's up
so I have a question
um my wife and I have been paying off
debt for about the last year and a half
now we've been able to pay off about 60
000 out of a hundred
and um I actually didn't know about uh
the baby steps until about six months
ago so at the beginning we were kind of
Davis
um I guess you could say and now we're
trying to get a little more uh gazelle
intense with it
um we've been doing pretty well with
following a budget
and um
I just am struggling with certain
expenses
um related to like family events I don't
get together with my family very often
we have a wedding coming up that we're
going to
uh and then I just found out from my
sister that um for her 40th birthday she
wants us to fly out to California and
spend a weekend with her at a resort
and uh it's gonna it's gonna cost us a
little over a thousand dollars for me to
go do that um I'm having a hard time
deciding whether or not that's a good
way to go we have I have just my student
loans left to pay off about 40 000 um I
was really hoping to knock that out
we've been able to increase our income
um so I've been hoping to be able to do
that in the next few months and I'm just
not sure whether or not that's a good
idea and I thought I'd get your advice
yeah I mean Tyler the I mean the reality
is we always say that the deeper you
sacrifice the more money that's on the
debt obviously the faster it's going to
be paid off but life is going to be
intertwined throughout that and that's
when you and your wife have to kind of
make the call yourselves and to say okay
what are things going on that we feel
like we want to be a part of uh with our
family what are things that we feel like
gosh we do but then we also are like we
could do something else at a later date
because we want this mess cleaned up so
again it goes back to because when we
get the we get this type of call the
time of like yeah we have a you know my
brother is getting married across the
country what do we do
um so I mean again it's one of those
things that you guys have to decide is
this going to this is going to slow us
down in our debt payoff but is it worth
it for what we're doing with our family
so I mean the problem Tyler
is this
every time you let one of these things
in
you not only lose the money
towards your get out of debt plan but
you lose
10x
the emotional momentum
because your lack of commitment
to the process your lack of intensity to
the idea of getting out of debt is
chipped away at and finally it just
doesn't matter and you stay in debt and
you're a freaking normal broke American
that goes to his sister's 40th birthday
on a freaking airplane
and that's what happens yeah and uh you
know all of a sudden you just look up
and you just got fat financially and and
it's one hamburger at a time you know
and so it's not the thousand dollars
it's the lack of you guys being dialed
in and going game on I got one plan for
a short period of time I'm gonna take no
prisoners nothing's going on this
complete emotional sellout and focus to
winning the Super Bowl is the only way
you win the Super Bowl no one half butts
their way into the Super Bowl
and that's what you got to get that's
what the what you've got to decide it's
the emotional problem the math really
isn't the problem it's this is but it's
this amen and then well and then yeah
and then when then we're going I'm kind
of tired I think I'll go out to eat well
why call the wambulance get your butt in
gear and get out of debt you know and
that's that's the kind of thing that's
the internal self-talk that has to
change you've got to get this commitment
up and that's the problem and it's not
I'm not mad at your sister and but you
you know broke people that are forty
thousand dollars in debt on stupid but
student loans shouldn't be getting on an
airplane to go to somebody's birthday
party think about it man that's just a
dumb statement
he is I know but I feel Tyler and like I
get it but I'm telling you this is this
is what yes
I'm saying Tyler this is how you talk to
yourself
just how you talk to yourself you got to
go I'm too stinking broke to go up there
because I'm in student loan debt and I
can't do this right now but that's the
truth right but it's not me yelling at
Tyler I'm just saying this is the way
you have to you have to shift your brain
into this gear where you're just going
enough I'm not living this way anymore
but the and the hard thing is though is
that life now 40th birthday it's more
flippant than like a wedding or a
funeral like there are life events that
occur if listen if you have to be there
get your butt in your car and drive up
there then don't talk to me about buying
an airplane ticket when you're broke
seriously